hello reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm
John and this is Jay Washington people
you guys know Jay Washington from you
know the thing you're the trusty
sidekick podcast this is everybody's off
the dough but you know him from mr. ja j
j-- wet washing washing i follow him on
social media mr. Jay Washington I've
seen a plenty of times on Collider
videos and first thing I saw him on I
saw you on your very first appearance in
movie flex watch the whole thing like
yeah man then you've invited back on the
forum several even on screen junkies a
lot speaking of screen junkies this is
what we call transition in the business
Jay honest trailers the money we're
gonna watch the honest trailers for the
mummy today from our friends over at
screen jump which mommy is this one
hands down my favorite mummy starring
Tom Cruise Thomas the cruise be a little
bit tongue I tell somebody everybody was
like tigers can't be their sword I was
gonna tell you how you find out how
small Tom Cruise is watching it's not
possible three yeah the scene we run it
through a guy and all them elderly Asian
people are towering when there's an old
Asian man towering over you you are sort
is she today's picture today shout out
gonna be for totally jumbo totally
jumble totally example let's do it
brought to you by t-mobile
now Netflix is included sellouts broader
placements best white said was
co-sponsored sponsorship Paul you're
making money for this really what is
dead they rise again
and the past cannot State Barry for long
so when universal needed a cinematic
universe they took the rotting bloated
corpse oh sure experience the terror of
a film without a soul that likes the fun
of the brendan fraiser version this is a
horror of the original and settles into
its own still plan of action blockbuster
cliches an OP that managed to kill all
hype for the dark you know when you want
a burger franchise by grabbing it fools
been off-base you get the guy who did
exact same thing this spider-man no but
the first thing uses his powers for good
and right the Transformers movie oh he
did twice he's back and she's all hot
now complete with sexy henna tattoos the
pg-13 rating and the power to take
revenge on the world after they punished
her for making a deal with the devil
a deal they gave her the power to kill
two sleeping people in the baby not sure
you had to bring the devil into that
Savannah right because yeah by pairing
the magic dagger with a super gin they
kill the host before the original is
completed like this is exactly why
people don't go to lose any more weight
cheaper to shoot their you know meet
Nick Morton a younger man proof that
some people are such boring dicks and
even Tom Cruise can make them charming
watch it bubble from action scene to
exposition dog without pausing to
develop his character beyond home-school
Indiana Jones right on ever
disrespectfully I'm not interested in
archaeological truck it is rare
sorry bro see it's gotta rise it's in a
country guy on to the pain from
something laws
sit through this loose collection of
studio notes masquerading as a single
well also being so Vegas lobby you don't
know what's going on have to dine with
one unhealthy purpose holding it all
together
bake the dark universe happen as this
movie about a mummy stops dead in its
tracks to introduce its own version of
Nick Fury my name is general dr. Henry
Jekyll its own version of he or welcome
to the did you it's very old all the
spin-offs so excited you were still
alive
Missy pop-up so the prospect of an
action movie universe starting guys in
their fifties fighting over the 30s
excites you it's the crazy idea to and I
know this is best
just hear me out I actually do something
scary and original with a horror movie
doctor lady
MD monsters fighting monsters fighting
around the world a waste of a perfectly
good Courtney swarm of spiders a swarm
of rats i swarm of birds i swarm of
terrible reviews and brendan fraiser
would've been to throw the guy at cameo
where is he these days
Tom Cruise runs from sand this was so
rush they accidentally posted the
trigger without music or sound effects
[Music]
yes this is real what you'll float to
something something so no yeah they
played a like an IMAX theater they
released the trailer for it and there
was like missing sound effects and
missing it was like I'll put this out
how do you plan so I'm glad but
universally trying to do why wouldn't
you be eyes even the person running the
projector should have been like oh stop
the trailer for a second man so I just
come downstairs like I said like listen
we have a small interruption this
Charlie you just saw we're gonna men in
black noir lives for this one seat you
don't deserve this I think if the mummy
is one of the easiest movies to bag on
they came out this year absolutely yeah
good it's all right with everything
they're saying is it's very true and
their opinions are very accurate you
know I figure if we're gonna do a
reaction to this might as well give a
couple of opinions that I might slightly
disagree with it's open to debate here
in Washington to play here's the problem
with the money they were so focused
universe was so focused on the dark
universe and going for they didn't take
the time to say let's make a good first
movie yeah we gotta Russell Crowe we got
Tom Cruise we can do this just
yeah it felt like slowly over the course
the promotion of this movie they started
getting their idea for the dark universe
more and more solidified to the point
where before the movie came out there
was a dark universe trailer so it seems
like they've always had their sights
beyond this even though they already
have had one failed attempt to jump
started with Dracula huntable
I gotta say though I don't feel like Tom
Cruise phones it in in this movie I feel
like Tom Cruise is committed to what
he's doing I think the writing and the
direction is bad I think Tom Cruise is
giving his all in a movie that's bad so
it's performance is not you're gonna
look like it's not that he doesn't quite
fit yeah he was just he was just even
hunt yeah Ethan Hunt going through the
desert and then London I heard rumors
about stalkers being a producer on set
who's really controlling the situation
and I can see that knowing you Tom
Cruise is like I could kind of see him
doing that it's not a horror movie and
also a lot of people get mad at the
what's that actor's name the funny John
Johnson Jake Johnson doing the American
Werewolf in London thinking I guess you
can see that as a ripoff to me I kind of
thought that are paying tribute to
America although they didn't take full
advantage gonna take full of them taken
full advantage so it does feel like a
ripoff because they don't commit to it
all the way it's just the sort of same
it's a scene yeah couple scenes of the
same exact type of relationship like oh
you're a ghost I'm seeing who's gonna
warn me about stuff yeah now like the
idea of including that in a way but yeah
without anything to make it unique and
all and just stand out fully in just me
I were just gonna do this this is all
yeah should I be in a hole - oh yeah
well yes this is the exact difference
between omajin
aping it's just like they just ripped it
and in a movie filled with so many other
things like that it just yeah it just
doesn't go to help any cause people will
try to say The Mummy was a good film but
you have to like it for what it is what
is it because supposedly this movie is a
setup for something else yeah that was
all they were trying to hurry up in push
yeah that's all they were trying to
hurry
watch on this trailer broke that down I
don't get how Studios get it so wrong
when so many people who are his audience
members like us kid goes I'm making one
good movie that's it
she has an answer people yes you J
because the studio's feel we're
investing this money and we know what
people want because we know how people
will spend money to go see certain
people regardless because we make what
people want but you get that I'm just
like how can you miss the note on you
just gotta make a really good movie and
first and not so worried so much about
universe building right oh yeah we even
saw it dead DC does it cuz that's all it
is it's like that's what the spider-man
franchise
yeah it's called we we know people will
go see it regardless yeah so it doesn't
have to be a good movie people are gonna
spend money like they have commitment
issues people want to make this first
one as big and crazy and loud and I
grabbing as possible instead of you know
bothering to to bolster force I saw it
this weekend yes a bit you know how it
ends on a way by the time movies
complete you're like that's just a
complete film we technically don't even
need part two even though we're gonna do
anything to really try to set you up per
sequel you really know it's a sequel is
if you've seen the original miniseries
already we're at the book right you
that's only ready you'll know but if you
haven't you wouldn't watch so just like
a universe building should be I mean
it's not a universe by the way the hell
with penny we're still there clown 100%
I'm not scared plans either we have the
cutest baby face
I think that's what makes us have a
great chemistry together chemistry is
what I build I'm building if I Drive
wanted slide my diems ladies we're doing
you a favor
well guys thank you screen junkies for
making that video and letting us watch
that that was fantastic
listen subscriber screen junkies oh yeah
before this video is done that shout out
we promised totally jumble teach totally
jumbled he has a baby along the way Jay
congratulations as a dad let me tell you
you're a dad yes I have to give to
children I'm not in the mood to be a
stepdad I look you signed up for this I
have a 13 year old a 3 year old I
thought when we got into this Jay that I
didn't have to deal with baggage is not
valuable their own baggage okay they are
payments well totally jumbled this is a
look into your future right now along
the way selling those Star Wars
collectibles my friend I guarantee you
that blood and plasma and urine and
everything else that you can sell
because you can sell urine
see this is what I like to do for the
shoutouts TJ we'd like to give you
positive
I'm sure this urine is this Oh member of
Scientology okay do you understand that
if you want to survive being a new dad
you got to be a Scientology don't take
care of your kids for you yeah take care
of those kids for it and then your
things will be clear don't you want to
join our patreon for you subscribe to
the real rejects it doesn't do anything
click that notification bell you might
get notified who knows you'll probably
ignore it - on Humphrey on Twitter and
Instagram but most importantly thirsty
side trusty sidekick podcast 33 signed
on iTunes Oh mr. Jay Washington on
Twitter Instagram I should possibly try
stand-up maybe I will one day go to the
description box of find him take care
face